en época normal un partido de béisbol en
japon el deporte más popular del país se
asemeja a esto pero actualmente debido
al cob y los estadios están limitados a
una decena de miles de espectadores con
aficionados con tapabocas y sin derecho
a gritar en las tribunas un abrebocas
del ambiente de los juegos olímpicos
normalmente es más animado todo el mundo
motiva a los jugadores pero ahora ya no
es posible y me da un poco de tristeza
antes de clamar vamos a cada jugador
teníamos incluso un cántico para cada
uno había tambores trompetas mi hija
pensaba que hoy podríamos como de
costumbre cantar y gritar para motivar a
los jugadores entonces está un poco
decepcionada tras meses de duda el
comité organizador señaló cada evento de
los juegos olímpicos será limitado al
50% del público normal sin superar los
10.000 espectadores reglas que ya se
aplican en ciertos eventos deportivos en
japon con un servicio de seguridad que
reprime a los ruidosos
alguien de seguridad vino a hacernos una
advertencia hace un momento pero no
importa queremos divertirnos jugadores
no cantan si nuestras arengas
estos juegos olímpicos serán los menos
festivos de la historia pero tokio desea
que celebren la resiliencia del hombre
contra el coronavirus un deseo de sus
aficionados ganaremos la batalla al
coronavirus para ganar esta batalla
japón trata de transmitir confianza
marcas en el suelo a la salida de los
estadios que el desinfectante por todas
partes en cuanto a los 70 mil
participantes extranjeros estarán
encerrados en una burbuja como estos
atletas que se dirigen a una competencia
de preparación separados de los
japoneses por una cuerda no pueden
acercarse a la población necesito que
retroceda en un poco claro cuáles son
las reglas las reglas son que deben
conservar la distancia lo siento
porque estos juegos olímpicos alimentan
todos los temores los sondeos más
recientes indicarían que entre el 60 y
el 80 por ciento de los japoneses desean
su anulación o un nuevo aplazamiento
estoy preocupado la llegada de
extranjeros seguro tendrá un impacto hay
variantes que pueden propagarse en este
contexto vale la pena organizar estos
juegos olímpicos japoneses está
preocupado porque cuenta con muchos
adultos mayores y dicha población ha
sido poco vacunada tan sólo el 7% de los
japoneses han recibido sus 2 dosis el
archipiélago es el más atrasado de los
grandes países desarrollados el colmo
para este estado moderno que dispone de
un excelente sistema de salud
estos habitantes de tokio han esperado
durante meses
estoy tranquila ahora tengo muchas ganas
de ir a un restaurante o quedarme un
norte del tema
o por qué no pasar una noche en
disneylandia japón no ha logrado
acelerar su proceso de homologación de
vacunas protocolo que los condujo a un
largo período de pruebas domésticas
resultado tuvieron que esperar cinco
largos meses de más que reinó unido-
para empezar a usar las vacunas modernas
y hasta se mica un escándalo
administrativo y político para muchos
médicos
nosotros los médicos queríamos la vacuna
lo más pronto posible pero no sabíamos
cuándo estarían disponibles las dosis
entonces les preguntamos a las
autoridades locales nos volcamos hacia
la asociación de medicina pero no sabían
que contestarnos poder nuestro gobierno
está muy atrasado
si habría sido necesario que les dieran
dinero a las empresas farmacéuticas para
ayudarlas a prepararse bien
ellos siguen creyendo en la anulación de
los juegos
[Aplausos]
desde hace semanas están haciendo
escuchar su rabia
un evento como los juegos olímpicos
debería ser organizado en calma y en paz
pero ahora estamos en plena pandemia no
es el momento adecuado y la prioridad es
la vida de la gente el gobierno no apoya
a los hospitales y prefiere usar dinero
público para que una fracción de la
población pueda divertirse no es normal
este dinero viene en nuestros impuestos
entonces creo que debería ser usado en
nosotros por el bien común
[Música]
es como si buscáramos sembrar nuevas
semillas del virus en otoño la epidemia
podría retomar fuerza y estar fuera de
control tal vez se transforme en una
gran catástrofe frente a la alcaldía de
tokio tratan de interpelar a los poderes
públicos
y
[Música]
[Aplausos]
sus llamados no serán escuchados el
gobierno está decidido a ejecutar su
compromiso
yo creo que hay que hacer los juegos es
una responsabilidad de nuestro país
recientemente la cantidad de nuevos
contagios en japón ha empezado a
descender el estado de urgencia en tokio
fue levantado ya nada parece poder
impedir los juegos